la lumière change lutz amiens au juste
surtout quand on est en jeu koné peu
vite
pat a traversé la mise à flot attendait
fois la deuxième derrière avec le froid
et les journées plus en novembre est un
mois propice malheureusement accident
qui est impliquant des piétons qui sont
blessés au malheureusement khimar
sécurité des piétons de 65 ans et plus
et tout un défi d'ailleurs la ville de
montréal spvm ont lancé une campagne de
sensibilisation sur la sécurité des
aînés
la comédienne france castel y prête sa
voix elle est avec nous ce matin bonjour
lavier ça va très bien vous en compagnie
de sofia provost donc à genthod spvm
dont jean marc ayrault demande pourquoi
vous associer à cette campagne me sens
concerné pourrait semblant par moi même
et je suis une abc comme j'aime à le
dire une année bien conservé et j'ai
l'intention de demeurer et de aussi de
d'essayer de rayonner de propager la
bonne nouvelle de prendre soin de soi à
mes semblables parce que je pense que
c'est important parce que vous sentez en
danger ou vous quand vous traversez des
intersections morin au sort danger je
veux dire moi je suis quand même assez
alerte ou aux douches doivent inquiéter
c'est de bien respecter les signaux il y
signe ce qui des fois ma patience me
l'empêchent alors je prends conscience
de ce qu'il faut aussi vraiment faire sa
part j'en vois beaucoup par contre
qu'ils se sentent en danger
allez je pense qu'on peut les a aidés
aussi on peut il ya plein de choses ils
vont au label va faire des choses la
police va faire des choses et madame
bravo les statistiques sont
par beaucoup il y a plusieurs dans tout
les décès qui a permis des piétons
grande partie à fait ce sont des années
des gens de 65 ans et plus mais bon an
mal an le bilan routier montréalais nous
démontre que oui à des actions à faire
annuellement à peu près 25 décès sur nos
routes de ses médecins décèlent 60 %
représentent des piétons âgés de 65 ans
et plus d'où l'importance d'agir pour
sécuriser leurs déplacements à pied
comment on peut mieux outiller les
piétons plus âgés mais voyez vous cette
année en collaboration avec la ville de
montréal et la société de l'assurance
automobile du québec
on a tenu des campagnes sur le partage
de la route on a également procédé à de
l'affichage dans les abribus les
affiches correspondait à comment
traverser des bons comportements à
adopter le fonctionnement des feux pour
piétons parce que bien souvent assez
méconnu ou mal compris on a également
fait de l'affichage dans toutes les
bibliothèques présente sur l'île de
montréal
donc par des personnes tout à la
signalisation aussi qu'il peut être un
peu pitié des fois les réflexes sont pas
tout à fait là il fait noir en novembre
en hiver il fait noir les angles alors
je pense qu'il faut et surtout être
conscient et prendre le temps si on voit
quelqu'un est souvent aussi vous parler
aussi les nouveaux arrivants des fois
qu'ils comprennent pas bien les signes
il faut que celles concernées on est
tous ensemble de soins de nos semblables
on voit le feu de signalisation pour les
voitures juste à côté il ya le petit
nalisation pour pour les piétons on
entendait tout à l'heure des réactions
des gens qui disent non des fois on n'a
pas l'impression d'avoir assez de temps
pour traverser est ce qui est fait
auprès de la ville de montréal spvm pour
améliorer la situation est ce qu'on
compte ajouter de la signalisation ou
étirer le temps allongé le temps pour
traverser mais je sais que présentement
la ville de montréal travaille justement
à sécuriser davantage les carrefours
notamment avec la présence des feux pour
piétons
mais c'est sûr que tant que le travail
est pas tout fait sur l'île de montréal
bennoo le service de police mais pour
sensibiliser nos mains c'est que
justement pour les sensibiliser
lorsque vous traversez la rue adaptez
votre votre démarche donc c'est à dire
que partie lorsque le feux de piétons
apparaît si vous partez plus tard 6
turquie va vous manquer peut-être des
secondes pour terminer votre traverser
en toute sécurité
donc c'est de les sensibiliser également
le contact visuel avec les
automobilistes l'importance du contact
visuel si vous voyez pas l'automobile et
ça se peut qu'il vous voit pas donc
prenez pas pour acquis que vous avez vu
je vous suggère lorsque le conducteur
retourner à une intersection laisse le
passé malgré que vous avez la priorité
et après ça vous pourrez vous engager
dans le fond c'est pour votre sécurité
et on en remarque on partage de plus en
plus la haute avec oui les voitures les
bicyclettes des loups d'être active mais
c'est de plus en plus difficile
j'imagine particulièrement pour les plus
âgés de se retrouver là dedans c'est pas
facile le partage de la route d'où
l'importance les piétons sur les
trottoirs les utilisera la rue puis la
cohabitation avec les automobilistes
aussi et au but bienveillance pour tout
le monde enfin se regarde est capable de
se regarder de près par prenons de ta
laissons le temps quand on voit que des
personnes qui ont besoin d'un peu plus
pour traverser oui on peut même aider ça
s'appelle du bien aussi
est-ce que vous avez remarqué dans les
statistiques ce sera ma dernière
question des statistiques vous disiez
bon il ya beaucoup de mal heureusement
de blessés de décès chez les 65 ans et
plus
s'il y avait une problématique à régler
ce serait laquelle
je pense que ça serait au niveau du
partage de votre mail a traversé étant
donné les 65 ans de prendre conscience
que nos capacités sont diminués ce qui
fait que de prendre son temps si on n'a
pas
traverser peut-être attendre l'approché
feux de circulation pour avoir pour
avoir le temps de traverser en toute
sécurité
éviter de prendre des risques dans une
classe demander de l'aide en moi ça
m'arrive jean bouin qui demandent de
l'aide et on peut on peut les aider ça
nous a tous mpt et pourquoi pas en
offrir oui voilà france castel safia
provost merci beaucoup d'avoir été